- It was Sophia's birthday recently
and you bought a very
thoughtful gift for her, right?
- Yeah, I did.
So I, you know, I wanted to,
you buy your wife
flowers, the flowers die.
I wanted to get her flowers
that would last forever.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So, I enlisted the help of this-
- Harry Potter.
(laughs)
- Of this famous glass
sculptor named Martin Blank.
So, a lot of people know
the name Dale Chihuly
as far as glass sculpting goes.
Towards the end of Dale's career,
Martin was making a lot of
Dale's sculptures for him.
- Oh, his apprentice basically.
- Yeah.
And there's this brilliant glass
sculptor that's in Seattle.
And he said, "Hey, I'm gonna
be finishing up the sculpture.
Do you want to come to Seattle?
And I'll let you be a part
of it and I'll teach you."
- [Kelly] Oh, that's you.
- So, I was taught that that furnace,
that blast furnace is 2,250 degrees.
So, you have to be very
careful with everything.
And there's a dance, there's a movement,
there's a choreography.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
he was basically like,
"Here are the steps. 1, 2, 3, 4.
You got it?"
And it's like,
- "Okay."
- Yeah.
- You know, like, don't let anyone die.
- Don't die.
- Okay. Got it.
And you don't die, so.
- So, you did the whole thing?
- I did, yeah.
And I made her a surprise,
which I was making there
which I won't show what
the finish product is,
- Okay. I like that.
- But that's a surprise.
- That's so nice though.
That's so beautiful.
- Yeah.
- It's thoughtful.
- Yeah and I wanna be a
part of it so that like,
I could always be a
part of that sculpture.
- Yeah.
- She knows like,
know that I made part of it.
- It's nice too because you can both buy
whatever you wanna buy,
you know what I'm saying?
But to make something for
someone, it's beautiful.
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- To be a part of it.
- I think that's more
meaningful. Just saying.